Today we will discuss two other very general AR methods of
problem solving called means end analysis and problem reduction.
Like [INAUDIBLE] these two methods, means analysis and
problem reduction, are really useful for very well-formed problems.
Not all problems are well-formed. But some problems are. And then these methods
are very useful. These three methods, generate and test, means-ends analysis,
form reduction, together with semantic networks as a knowledge representation,
form the basic unit of all fundamental topics in this course.
We'll begin with the notion of state spaces. Then talk about means-end analysis.
Then we'll illustrate means-end analysis as a matter for
solving problems and then we'll move onto the method of problem reduction.